good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight most people got poorer
during the covid lockdowns probably
poorer than they realize they're finding
out now unfortunately but the tech
companies got a whole lot richer and
it's simple why politicians forced the
entire population indoors at gunpoint so
millions of people had no choice but to
live out their lives in the lonely hell
of the internet
that turned out to be a disaster for
America as rising suicide rates now a
test but for Silicon Valley it made for
an epic payday that epic payday was soon
reflected epically on the balance sheets
of its biggest local lenders which was
called Silicon Valley Bank
in 2018 svb had about 49 billion dollars
on deposit three years later that same
bank had amassed more than 189 billion
that is a gargantuan increase in
deposits over a very short period of
time it was certainly dramatic enough to
have raised a very serious question and
an obvious one what was Silicon Valley
Bank gonna do with all that money
even in the San Francisco Bay Area it
would be hard to find Qualified
borrowers for 189 billion dollars you
could not responsibly loan all of that
money even if you wanted to
so what would you do with it now that's
the question you would have asked if you
were paying attention both from inside
svb or from the federal regulatory
agencies in Washington but it turns out
nobody was paying attention nobody
thought to ask that or many other
questions and we thought stress test
Silicon Valley Bank in the middle of a
boom
and of course that turned out to be a
great mistake
but the remaining question is what were
they doing at svb and at the other banks
that have either failed or come close to
failing over the last week
well they were doing what you would do
if you were a mediocre but highly
credentialed irresponsible person with a
narcissism complex who talked a lot
about your Ultra marathons and you're
coming to climate change
if the Central Bank handed you trillions
of dollars free with no strings attached
you would party like it was 1999 or to
update the reference you would virtue
signal like it was 2023 you would spend
hundreds of millions of dollars bragging
about what a good person you are and
that of course is exactly what they did
consider signature bank now Signature
Bank was shut down by federal Regulators
this weekend on Sunday because it posed
an imminent threat to the entire
Financial system its demise marked the
third largest bank collapse in American
history
why did Signature Bank fail
we could give you the technical
math-based answer but here's the real
reason Signature Bank failed because it
was corrupt
that's a strong charge how do we know
that well simple
its directors gave Barney Frank a board
seat
that's it Frank is the same person who
was a member of Congress of
Massachusetts wrote the banking
regulations imposed on Signature Bank
and all the other banks by Washington
after the 08 collapse
Barney Frank has never had a real job he
has spent his entire life in politics
he's elderly now but he has no relevant
experience or expertise so the only
reason that Signature Bank hired him is
because he once regulated Signature Bank
now if we were looking at a foreign
country we'd describe that instantly as
what a payoff
the people who actually ran Signature
Bank meanwhile the so-called Bankers did
not seem to spend a lot of time Banking
and of course they didn't need to bank
really because the Fed was guaranteeing
them a never-ending torrent of cash in
the form of free money so what did they
do
well here is Scott Shea the chairman of
Signature Bank welcoming his employees
to a meeting of the bank's critical
Pride Council
this video is from last December just
months before Signature Bank slipped
beneath the waves and the pride Council
in question as you will see in a moment
featured a self-described genderqueer
transmasculine person called Finn
Brigham who arrived to teach employees
about pronoun use watch I'm Scott Shea
chairman of Signature Bank and it is a
pleasure for me to welcome you to this
multi-media multicasted multi-spatial
meeting of the pride Council and I'm
just thrilled that there are about 40
people in the room I understand there
are something like 190 people that watch
parties so hi to you all at the watch
parties you know the most common
pronouns that folks are familiar with
are she and he becoming much more common
and you know I don't know if there's
anyone in the Signature Bank world but
probably you have clients that use they
them as pronouns they're gender neutral
pronouns on purpose we talked about
folks that are non-binary that
intentionally don't identify as male or
female so some of those folks you
Tuesday them as their pronouns Z is
another gender-neutral pronoun and the
other part of that would be here spelled
h-i-r
Scott Shea is just thrilled to introduce
the genderqueer trans masculine pronoun
expert and to host watch parties so
everyone out and watch him explain
Prince
what do they pay that guy what did they
pay that guy how much will they have to
pay you to swallow your dignity
to completely eliminate the possibility
that your children would ever respect
you in order to put on a performance
that embarrassing probably a lot we
don't know what he was paid clearly a
lot clear the bank a lot of money
because trans pronoun experts are not
cheap at all
but signature did have a lot of cash of
course because the Federal Reserve was
printing it and they got the first pass
this is what low interest rates for 13
years means
so again this was going on for years
here for example signature Banks music
video did you know Banks made music
videos of course they did they didn't
know what else to else do with the money
this one is from 2011.
show your clients
[Music]
sorry it was a dance party at Signature
Bank
like there was banking going and it was
a dance party at Signature Bank with
pronouns
and that's not the only video from
Signature Bank like that you can go
online and find many others including
their Broadway inspired sketches you
could spend all day watching these
videos we just did and are better off
for it but it's not just signature the
guy ran signature was really craving and
repulsive but he's not alone
no one at any of these Banks seem to
spend a lot of time banking
which the rest of us believed was the
core business of a bank but no in fact
at Silicon Valley Bank only a single
member of the board had any experience
at Investment Banking the rest were
Silly Rich ladies The Daily Mail reports
that every other member of the board was
an Obama or Clinton Mega donor one silly
Rich lady was such a sensitive soul of
course she was that she had to go to a
Shinto Shrine to pray When Donald Trump
won in 2016. we looked up her picture
she doesn't seem like a native born in
Shinto but whatever
there was a lot of fashionable rich girl
politics underway at Silicon Valley Bank
but banking not so much
svb had no head of risk management for
nine months in the year before it
collapsed oh I guess someone should have
been paying attention but no they're
visiting Shinto shrines they make dance
parties with their pronouns
meanwhile Silicon Valley Bank UK that
would be the UK arm of Silicon Valley
banking because the name didn't give it
away
did have a head of risk management
unfortunately the head was called Jay
air Sapa who didn't seem to know a lot
about managing risks or care she talked
mostly about herself because it's so so
fascinating to talk about yourself a lot
me me enough of your risk management
let's talk about me and she did
at one point she described herself as a
quote queer person of color from working
class background oh yes narcissism is so
much more fun than banking so needless
to say the risk manager was working hard
on
lgbtqia plus plus plus rights
how did that end how does it work if you
run a bank like this and people just
talk about themselves and their
identities as if those are interesting
topics
well this week silicon Valley's UK Banks
UK Branch sold
for the fully publicly disclosed sum of
one dollar one dollar for the bank
but as you would imagine in a bank where
nobody cared about risk management the
collapse was pretty entertaining for the
rest of us of course there's a tragedy
at the core that imperils the entire
Western economy but the good news is we
have videos like this this is a video
that svb put out days before it went
under
I think there's a big disparity between
the Investments and blacklight companies
than other companies we want to help
close the Latino wealth Gap
more entitled people talking about
themselves let's talk about me and my
identity it's so interesting banking is
boring the fed's got that covered
is this starting to scare you a little
bit this is what banks are actually like
and we don't want to alarm anybody or
get censored by Senator Mark Kelly of
Arizona who's now on the record saying
he does not want you complaining about
Banks
but we should tell you it's not just
signature svb officials who talk like
that JP Morgan
it's the biggest bank in the world we
think as of tonight one of the few banks
that consumers still have some
confidence in put out a whole video
about how they give out money not on the
basis of Economics or math but on the
basis of irrelevant characteristics like
your appearance they're judging the book
by its cover watch
the events of Summer 2020 highlighted
long-standing inequalities particularly
among the black Hispanic and Latino
communities that has had a significant
impact on our country at JPMorgan Chase
a key goal is to help break down
systemic barriers that have created
profound disparities that's why we
committed 30 billion dollars towards
racial Equity to provide resources and
opportunity for our black Hispanic and
Latino communities we've invested more
than 100 million dollars in
minority-owned Banks across the country
and are building a more Equitable and
representative Workforce we're committed
to racial equity
wait a second am I getting a moral
lecture from a bank from a bank really a
bank is telling America
how to live describing Americans since
you're a bank where's the left by the
way
90 years ago in the 1930s the last Great
Depression nobody would have sat still
from a moral lecture delivered by a bank
but they're very common now why
well a little history after 2008 a
movement emerged called occupied Wall
Street at the time it was at The Cutting
Edge of left-wing social activism and it
did seem kind of organic most of these
things are completely fake like BLM
obviously orchestrated but Occupy Wall
Street seemed kind of real it seemed
like angry people and some people from
Occupy Wall Street turned their
attention to the head of JP Morgan
of course is Jamie Diamond they went to
his office they held signs outside for
24 hours a day and they hassled other
bank presidents too and before long a
funny thing happened everybody in the
media decided that Occupy Wall Street
was boring
anything about economics was boring
because who cares about carried interest
what's that
what we really want to talk about they
told you is racial oppression and your
role in it
and so we got a lot of that only for
like 12 years now an endless parade of
lies about this or that your complicity
and systemic racism police shootings
they're everywhere everyone's getting
killed by the cops hands up don't shoot
remember that
so we're all still talking about that
nonsense ripping the country apart along
racial lines but guess what we're not
talking about oh Banks I guess who loves
that Banks they deeply appreciate that
and maybe that's why as BLM rioters
torch major cities Democrats who took
big money from Big Banks knelt in
reverence to BLM
we are here to honor George Floyd
in a moment we will have a moment of
silence actually eight minutes and 46
seconds of Silence in honor of George
Floyd and so many others
who lost their lives or were abused by
police brutality for those who wish to
we will now kneel for our moment of
silence
[Music]
oh so great what is everybody in that
frame have in common well if kenty cloth
robes on a lot of them are wearing masks
no but they're all Bank shills that's
what it is they're all Bank shills
they're shills for finance of course
every single one of them and
particularly the utterly soulless Nancy
Pelosi she'll say anything on behalf of
the banks the banks love this of course
they want to make sure it continued and
that's why according to amazing new
analysis from The Claremont Institute
Silicon Valley Bank brace yourself spent
more than 73 million dollars on
donations to BLM and related
organizations
wow and this is not personal funds
apparently these are Bank funds might be
kind of nice to have that money now but
it's hard to argue even in retrospect
now that svb has failed that was a bad
investment
because even now as banks are collapsing
no one immediate is anxious to criticize
Banks almost no matter what they do it
doesn't matter what they do even if they
were to just pulling inside of thin air
openly profiteer from a war in Eastern
Europe that's killing hundreds of
thousands of people oh it turns out they
are and we know that because zielinski
the president of Ukraine and a very
close friend of Banks and BlackRock is
bragging about it watch
it is obvious that American Business can
become the locomotive that will once
again push forward global economic
growth we have already managed to
attract attention and have cooperation
with such Giants of the International
Financial and investment world as
BlackRock GP Morgan and golden socks
so we're getting moral lectures from the
banks and we're getting a lecture on
capitalism from some Ukrainian oligarch
in a sweatshirt okay now
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight